We all know space rocks, but what about the
rocks in space?
Asteroids, Comets, and Meteors are hurtling
through the solar system.
So how do you tell them apart and which rocks
could hit our planet? Comets pass near Earth
but they never make it to the surface.
These cosmic snowballs form overtime in the
outer reaches of the solar system and are
made up of ice, rock and metal.
If a comet gets too close to the sun, some
of the ice heats up and turns into a gas,
creating a glowy layer and that famous tail.
If a comet were to shed its ice, it’d become
an asteroid.
Meh.
These space rocks can be as big as an entire
country or as small as a chihuahua head.
Most of the time, you can find them hanging
out in the asteroid belt, a rocky superhighway
between Mars and Jupiter.
Pieces of rock that break off asteroids and
comets are called meteoroids.
When a meteoroid enters the Earth’s atmosphere,
it burns up and causes friction that results
in a light phenomena.
The streak of light is known as a meteor or
a shooting star.
And if a meteoroid lands on Earth’s surface,
ah runaway, it becomes a meteorite.
So the next time you’re gazing at the sky
at a shooting star, you’ll know exactly
what it is… and exactly what it isn’t.
You can catch more episodes of Galactic Glossary
every Wednesday and to learn more about space
rocks, like the one that triggered the demise
of the dinosaurs, check out this video here.
Thanks for watching and let us know what you
think in the comments below.